[ __ ] inside myself
what's up you guys my name is Hal and
last night I saw a wonder Mormon so I
decided to leave work early and take a
subway down to Chinatown and now I'm
here at this website or we've done
sending them happen and you're kinda
lactose I can make my torches like
Wonder Woman
[Music]
I also bought a Wonder Woman costumes
that like to make my co-workers look
silly I was very very eager excited to
see Wonder Woman I just saw it recently
like two days ago and my mind is blown
it took like a week to get tickets I
could not do anything that Wonder Woman
does Wonder Woman is she's she's fierce
I never tried lassoing but I've
definitely done it on the dance floor
like mimed it out but that's about it
okay so I'm about to watch this video of
how to throw a rope lasso or this guy as
we way too much skill teach me daddy
what are people a so anyway cows they
may seem like witches out here doing
just a regular snuggler thing oh [ __ ]
that actually what car creepy I could do
it probably
[Music]
oh my god are you kidding could you have
just untangled this for me at least all
right well this is complicated
I'm so confused look it impossible are
you kidding what have been doing feel
like as full as way bigger though and
then he just is a simple oh I just I
just hooked the damn computer
I don't know how Wonder Woman does this
let alone a cowboy I'm so terrified this
is Kara my everything anyway I've got
more [ __ ] to handle oh no no no no
everybody wants to be in about the video
yeah yeah yeah yeah alright I feel even
better about this because got my hand
shield my other shield [ __ ] for real I
honestly have no strategy I literally
don't know what I'm doing I'm going to
start with the angry one because he
looks like he's pissed and we don't need
that kind of energy and 2017 okay oh I'm
pretty sure I did this is so hard
how do you expect me to do this with a
shield
[Music]
yes all around come around damn it
[ __ ] that's how you [ __ ] laugh though
right
the idea of using this to hurt hurt
anyone or fight any crime is beyond me I
don't know how she does it I mean this
was really challenging but yeah just
anyone that uses the lasso room I have
respect for now I still beat the
villains so I'm pretty proud of what I
accomplished so Wonder Woman sorceress
planned a thousand men for breakfast I
tried I still a Wonder Woman listen but
this is not for Katie okay so what have
we learned today honestly not that much
one last thing is really hard to do -
Wonder Woman amazing character with a
lot of really awesome superpowers so
yeah go Wonder Woman and also my
quarters really love dressing
[Music]